When actors have a relationship off camera,
it can make things awkward on camera,
which the stars of a certain low-budget
'90s movie know better than anybody. And
that's not the only time cinematic love
scenes have gotten majorly uncomfortable.
Love scenes aren't just for romantic comedies.
They can appear in all sorts of movies,
even the most serious of serious dramas.
Quite frankly, audiences can often be in the
mood for some kind of romantic interlude
just to break the tension. Then again,
just because a movie can have a love
scene doesn't mean that it should.
Case in point: the 2005 historical drama
Munich. If there's any movie that doesn't
need a steamy encounter, it's almost certainly
one about Israeli assassins sent to avenge the
deaths of athletes who were killed by
terrorists at the 1972 Summer Olympics.
After spending a very long time hunting down
terrorists, Avner, played by Eric Bana, has
sex with his wife. The action cuts between their
wild ecstasy and violent images of people being
gunned down at an airport. To be fair, director
Steven Spielberg was probably just trying to be
both artful and cathartic with this scene. And
after all, it's not like intercutting sex with
violence hasn't been done before. But that doesn't
make it any less uncomfortable in this case.
After three movies about an evil doll possessed by
the soul of a serial killer, the team behind the
Child's Play franchise needed to expand their
universe. And so, they decided to have Chucky
take a lover. 1998's Bride of Chucky finds the
titular killer doll reconnecting with Tiffany,
his girlfriend from his time as a human.
After he kills her, he then transfers her
soul into the body of a bride doll that looks
like a blond, female version of himself.
A bloody crime spree from
these two psychopaths follows,
and that isn't exactly a good environment
for a love scene. But this moment was always
going to be strange and uncomfortable, as it
involves the most intimate acts rendered with
the best technology and puppetry that
a mid-budget '90s movie had to offer.
After Chucky proposes marriage, amorous
feelings quickly take over. There's a lot
of loud open-mouth kissing from two characters
whose mouths don't really move, as well as
stripping in front of a roaring fire and the two
dolls doing the deed in a silhouette that leaves
little to the imagination. Making things even
more unbearable are all the cheesy wisecracks.
"I am anatomically correct, you know."
"Ohhhh."
Few films have received the level of critical
derision and simultaneous fan acclaim suffered
by Fifty Shades of Grey. That's probably
because most of the people who like the
movie are also fans of the novels that
feature infamously corny sentences like,
"My inner goddess is doing the
merengue with some salsa moves."
So it's no surprise then that the movie
version presented the same heavy-handed,
implausible romance that sees mousy
virgin Anastasia Steele transformed
into a kinky submissive at
the hands of Christian Grey.
Each love scene escalates further and further
into ridiculousness to the point that the
climax of the film occurs when Anastasia
freaks out after Christian spanks her too
hard. This happens in his so-called "play
room," which features hooks, whips, chains,
and all manner of medieval-looking torture devices
that Anastasia seemingly has no issue with.
"Stop! No!"
The 2009 sci-fi horror movie Splice
raises a lot of questions about the
moral implications and personal ramifications
of science, particularly the rapidly evolving
discipline of genetic engineering. While working
at a scientific facility called Nucleic Exchange
Research and Development, genetic engineers Clive
and Elsa, played by Adrien Brody and Sarah Polley,
develop a viable creature by mixing human
DNA with genetic materials from animals.
Elsa names this creature "Dren," which is "nerd"
backwards, and then she grows from a child to a
young woman very quickly. Clive clearly finds Dren
to be very beautiful, although she's more animal
than human with her giant eyes, long tail,
and feet that look like hands. It's obvious
that we're building to some kind of intimate act
between Clive and Dren, but that doesn't make it
any less weird when it happens. And it does indeed
happen, in a barn where Dren has been locked up,
no less. It's basically like Clive is getting
busy with his coworker and his pet all at once.
MacGruber began as a recurring bit on Saturday
Night Live that parodied the action-adventure TV
show MacGyver, which starred Richard Dean Anderson
as a genius who could save the day by making
life-saving inventions out of household materials.
But in the SNL version, Will Forte plays MacGruber
as a supposed genius who would try to do the same
thing but inevitably always fail explosively.
When MacGruber became a movie in 2010, it
needed to be fleshed out significantly for
a feature-length running time, so it
wound up as a parody of over-the-top
'80s action movies. Amidst all the
explosions and lone-wolf theatrics,
those films usually also include a
steamy love scene, and so does MacGruber.
As Mr. Mister's power ballad "Broken Wings"
plays, MacGruber begins to make sweet love
to his wife Casey in her wedding gown. But
then things get hilariously weird and dark.
The music falls away, and viewers see a
bare-bottomed MacGruber grunting away in
a graveyard while a groundskeeper watches.
Casey actually died earlier in the movie,
which is re-established with a cut back
to MacGruber, who's now standing nude in
a graveyard at night, moaning and talking
dirty to a ghost that nobody else can see.
"Just tell me what you want me to f---!"
The twisty 2003 Korean thriller Oldboy
from writer-director Park Chan-wook
won numerous awards on the festival circuit
and eventually became an international cult
favorite. It's not only one of the most
acclaimed South Korean films ever made,
it also helped put the country's cinema on the
map. Without Oldboy, Parasite may never have
become an Oscar-winning phenomenon. In the midst
of the twisty and unpredictable plot, there's a
love scene that becomes disturbing in retrospect
after all the mysteries have fully unraveled.
In the opening scenes, the protagonist Oh Dae-su
is arrested one night for public drunkenness,
which causes him to miss his young
daughter's birthday party. After a
friend retrieves him from the police station,
he's kidnapped and isolated in a hotel room
for 15 years. When he's finally released, he
wanders into a sushi restaurant and strikes
up a relationship with young chef Mi-do.
He tries to get his life back together,
though he gives up on finding his daughter when he
learns that she was adopted by a Swedish couple.
Then his captor Lee Woo-jin contacts Dae-su
and gives him an ultimatum. If he guesses
the reason for his imprisonment within
five days, Woo-jin will kill himself;
if not, he'll kill Mi-do. Dae-su and Mi-do's
relationship grows increasingly intimate,
and Dae-su soon figures it all out.
He went to high school with Woo-jin,
and he saw him engage in incest with his sister.
Dae-su spread the news, and the sister was so
mortified that she killed herself. It would seem
that Woo-jin has had his revenge on Dae-su with
the years-long imprisonment. But as it turns
out, his plan was even more sinister than that,
as the climactic scene revealed that Dae-su's
long-lost daughter is actually Mi-do.
Before he became an Oscar winner for Green Book,
Peter Farrelly and his brother Bobby made some of
the most outrageous comedies of the '90s, like
There's Something About Mary, Dumb and Dumber,
and Kingpin. That last one stars Woody Harrelson
as down-on-his-luck former bowling champion Roy
Munsen. An attempt to hustle amateur bowlers goes
poorly, and he loses his hand in a ball return
accident. Two decades later, he's reduced to
selling bowling supplies and spending most of his
time drinking. He has little choice but to get in
bed with his landlady, played by frequent Farrelly
collaborator Lin Shaye, so that she'll be more
forgiving with his perpetually late rent payments.
That's the uncomfortable setup: a man who suffers
from excessive drinking use has to prostitute
himself to avoid becoming homeless. There's
an even more unsettling payoff. Roy stages an
attack on the landlady so as to chase the guy
off and earn himself some favor. But she finds
out about it and then forces him to make it up
to her in the bedroom. Then it cuts to her lying
in bed smoking a cigarette in post-coital bliss
while Roy throws up in the adjoining bathroom.
"You still owe me another month's rent."
Almost any love scene in a comedy could make
this list, as they're usually played for awkward
laughs. But 2009's Observe and Report isn't your
standard comedy. It's a dark and twisted flick
written and directed by Jody Hill, the creator
of the HBO series Eastbound & Down. When mall
security officer Ronnie, played by Seth Rogen,
finally lands his dream girl Brandi, played by
Anna Faris, their romantic encounter is rather
seedy. They're both drunk, which already means
that they're not thinking straight and can't give
informed consent. Nevertheless, they go back to
her place for sex, even though Brandi has ingested
a lot of clonazepam and is only semi-conscious.
Observe and Report tries to
recover this scene with a joke,
as the passed-out Brandi wakes up and asks
Ronnie why he's stopping. But at that point,
the creepiness is just too much, and we're
witnessing a gross exploitation of a terrible
situation. Although considering how dark this
movie is, that may have been intentional.
The 1995 erotic thriller Showgirls came hot on
the heels of director Paul Verhoeven's iconic run
of RoboCop, Total Recall, and Basic Instinct. So
he was probably looking for a similarly visceral
response when he took on the world of showgirl
dancers in Las Vegas. Unfortunately, he made a
film that's had a rocky reception at best. Some
critics cited its campy melodrama as a detraction.
And sure, if you're not on the film's unusual
wavelength, it may feel like something that
would be more at home on Lifetime, if not for the
graphic sex, particularly the infamous pool scene.
Elizabeth Berkley plays the lead character of
Nomi Malone, who writhes around on top of Kyle
MacLachlan like someone just threw a toaster
into the water. If you can manage to wipe away
your tears of laughter, you can literally
see all the stunned confusion written all
over his face. But Verhoeven's reputation has
endured beyond Showgirls, and the film itself
has since been rediscovered and reevaluated
by a new generation of audiences and critics.
"It doesn't suck."
1997's Kickboxing Academy was also
released under the far more boring,
if accurate, title "Teen Boxer."
The plot, naturally enough,
concerns the day-to-day activities at a
kickboxing academy. Ultimately, the kids
at the academy have to square off against
the kids from another martial arts school.
Among those kickboxing kids are a couple
of fresh-faced teenagers named Cindy and
Danny. They're played by Chyler Leigh, years
before she starred in Not Another Teen Movie
and Grey's Anatomy, and Christopher Khayman
Lee, who's probably best known for multiple
Power Rangers series. In real life,
the two of them are brother and sister,
which makes the fact that their characters are
romantically involved the height of awkwardness.
And the people making Kickboxing Academy
apparently didn't think it was too weird
to include multiple scenes in which Cindy
and Danny passionately kiss each other.
At the end of 2000's Requiem for a
Dream, each of the main characters
are deep in the worst chapters of their
addictions. Jennifer Connelly plays Marion,
a heroin addict who resorts to selling her
body for the drug when she's recruited into
doing a show for a bunch of salivating men who
jeer and throw money at her and another woman.
To be fair, this isn't so much a love scene as
it is a horrifically graphic act that occurs
amid a swirling, brilliantly edited sequence
that weaves together the awful predicaments
that each character has found themselves in.
On top of that, it also imparts their panic
and despair onto the audience through a
jarringly effective use of shock value.